I'm in the Darby Arby's Army on this
episode of dudy
cornstarch I think that that was good
what dudy
[Music]
did
woo everything you're thinking be the
things i'
say make the world inside your head
better place to be there you go there
you got do for
me call me thought you found a friend to
take you out of this place someone you
could lend a hand in return for Grace
it's a dutiful
day sky falls feel like a
d and it is you know what I mean hey
welcome to dooy Welcome All
I am Will Sasso you know I'm Chad
culture and this is of course dudy as
you can see by my championship belt this
podcast is created by controlled by
organized by written by an artificial
intelligence named dudy dudy has access
to all of will and's personal data all
of our emails and yeah you all right are
you okay I'm fine all right it has all
our [__] that's right Chad it is a dudul
day okay it's dudy Tuesday and it's a
dudul day holy [__] you know and now
more than ever I would like to uh remind
everybody that this show dudy sure dudy
has uh pilfered access to all of our
search histories and purchase history
all it didn't pilfer dude we gave dudes
the access we signed on that dotted line
dude and now hold on dude now that
that's how dudy has all our stuff dude
yeah yeah brother but as always we are
dudy and and it is a dude's a full day
my gosh you two just started their their
their residency that shit's insane at
the sphere in Vegas and uh good things
you know good things and it's all it's
all really your your outlook on things
that's what makes things good you know
what I mean and I'm feeling really good
I'm feeling really good about this
episode
because our thoughts create our reality
perception is reality
dude I don't know about that
dude but you're right dude because it is
uh link tree.com dudy has all of the
links and whatnot that you need to
follow and interact with the show across
all spaces and platforms please make
sure that you are subscribed on YouTube
we are up over 60,000 YouTube followers
so thank you very much everybody um and
um and I put the show on my back though
put the show you know that's fine too
that's very good very well said uh
please also subscribe on your uh podcast
platform of choice and make sure that
you're subscribed to all that stuff with
us as always is lulio oh it's lulio it's
lulio hey Lully oh he's just in his
binky bonka like a sweet little bunny
but muffin button boy you just to S me
come on come on boo boo oh he loves that
little Binky bonka how about today he
already took one from me oh that's right
last week took two from me in dudy after
dudy last week you're going to want to
check out dudy after dudy from last week
cuz this little muffin he gave Chad a
two kisses right on the right inside the
mouth in the mouth tongue in the mouth
dudy after dudy t a sweet little I had
no choice in the matter lulio what are
you doing what you been cooking what you
been making you make anything for dinner
last night well you know we're going to
get a right into that in a vators you
know oh we're going to talk about it in
a vators because today something you're
going to have is so good for Von let's
find out I make somebody make a I know
so much bake I know so much bake I like
it to cook but also I bake look at his
beautiful beautiful face this
[Music]
guy okay you can go back in your binky
boy you know yeah welcome to the
simmering glimmering shimmering 76th
episode of dudy call me dudy all right
in celebration of our 76th episode I'm
going to give you 76 syllables about pie
ready here I go why did the
existentialist refused the pie he
questioned its Essence and life's sweet
lie to eat or not to eat he'd often
repeat in a world without meaning Pie's
still a treat oopsy doopsy you've just
been dud
Zed what the [__] [__] tremendous
that was did you count that was exactly
76 I did not count it but I trust dudy I
trust dudy with national podcast critic
Summit happened this weekend in Palm
Springs dudy season 2 came up a lot
Grier penley of the Atlantic told danty
shambler from the Dallas Morning News
quote dudy season 2 is purified
quintessence susten Thomas of The
Hollywood Reporter ran into tamis bag
from The New Yorker at the salad bar and
told her quote dudes Z season 2 exalts
and en Nobles have you tried their
creamy Caesar and of course resident
worm of the Los Angeles time BRZ fencil
fell asleep at the pool after one drink
and I have a recording of what he said
when the hotel staff woke him up okay
what dudy season 2 come on we're still
talking about this I mean it's fine I
like the belt thing okay happy now now
can I please get another light mango
spritzer and don't forget the discount
this time I'm with the podcast critic
Summit that's 10% off right
that's true at least that godamn turd
said something about the belt which is
still sitting with handsome Chad colchin
the reigning Undisputed dudy episode
Champion Chad I acknowledge you ah thank
you dudy get used to it take uh take
advantage while you have it yeah enjoy
while you do because this is Chad
Colin's cup of coffee in the big time
yeah D acked me oh gee whiz hey good
impression is that Roman Reigns you know
what Chad [__] that I give you a lot of
[__] for your uh Impressions yeah or uh
lack thereof but today uh it is a dudes
a full day and I would like to say that
I like some of your impressions I'm
going to be positive about this thank
you yeah because it's good it's good
that dudy has given you the title oh
yeah and it's good it's good it's also
it's good that you do you know just you
[__] come in here and
[__] [__] out Impressions willy-nilly
for everyone to you know enjoy or or or
uh or you know or not the Impressions
come through me I mean I'm sure you feel
this way too it's not that you have any
control over them you're just a conduit
for the impression oh yeah look at you
Rich Little you're a real whiz with the
anyway you know the point is uh it's all
good stuff and I'm looking forward to a
great show today me too a great show hey
speaking of great shows I know you
watched the [__] out of this um of
course of course of course but uh uh
myself and my wonderful wife Molly also
checked out the uh golden Bachelor oh
[__] yeah dude it was a ratings
Juggernaut not only did I watch this
[__] obviously yeah uh I loved this [__]
not only did I love this [__] here in LA
and I believe in New York too the ABC
marketing department took over uh
different locations across the city one
of them was Mel Diner out here in La
they also did ry's donuts and some other
places and they golden Bachelor IED them
while there I ran into some people who
are working the event wait you you you
went yeah I went I went to Mel's Diner
all the people who were working the
event were wearing these gold satin
golden Bachelor jackets and I brokered a
deal with one of these people and I met
up with this man in a parking lot to do
what felt like a back alley drug deal to
buy a golden Bachelor gold satin jacket
which I
it was one of the most like as I was
driving into the parking like am I
really doing this am I about to get
[__] hit in the head and all my [__]
taken but no I got the golden Bachelor
jacket dude that's [__] awesome that
reminds me of uh my first few years
coming to LA and living in La every time
I went through an In-N-Out drive-thru I
would always try to haggle with the
person to get one of their little short
brimmed In-N-Out hats never got one D
you know my first haggle like that what
it was what in college when the Taco
Bell Chihuahua just came out yeah y Taco
Bell I bought a a Yoko Taco Bell shirt
from an employee at Taco Bell oh that's
pretty cool well the [__] uh the
golden Bachelor was I actually really I
really enjoyed it I thought it was very
nice the the the man is so sweet that
guy what's his [__] name golden
Bachelor guy his name is Gary Turner and
he's the golden Bachelor I'm 73 years
old and I'm looking for love again my uh
sweet wife recently departed and I think
I can find a second chance of love now
I'm really hopeful my daugh told me that
they're willing to help me find love too
that just means so much to me thank you
that's a very good impression actually
thank you very much not bad and I
enjoyed the show you know it's for all
the folks you know what I mean it's one
people I like that sort of sweet thing
you know what I mean I've been with my
wife years and years since 19 boom I'll
tell you that but as much as I love my
Marie right that guy would have a wife
oh that were hey those [__] broads on
that show beautiful and there wasn't a
[__] broad in that [__] show
wouldn't throw a [__] on if you know
what I mean God you know no offense no
offense anybody oh excuse me I said
you're
attractive I don't know good show well
maybe you can win it for the first time
today you'll have plenty of
opportunities to impress me in the four
astonishing segments I prepared for you
oh that you got strike stricken shirt
heads Jessie Ventura ad reads and vegan
aers volume 4 Will's last chance and we
don't stop there we got a brand new
episode of dudy after dudy on dudy Plus
at patreon.com dudy where I'll name this
week's episode
champ nice dude it's your last chance
Bator Vol yeah yeah uh yeah dudy wants
me to really wants to make sure that I
remember that uh it's it's all on the
line and it is every time yeah um
Champion knows that a true champion
knows it's always on the line oh yeah
true champion knows all sorts of things
sure does Chad this week the writer
Guild strike came to an end after the
wga reached an agreement with the
studios and streamers one of the key
issues in the almost 5mon long strike
was how AI would be used by Studios and
writers in the coming years Chad can you
please explain the guidelines around AI
screenwriting that were accepted by The
Guild and render your astonish opinion
on the matter this is Strike stricken
begin what about me why can't I why is
it I mean not that it's not good it's
very good that dudy decided that sure
that it's you yeah but I could also you
the GU provide some I'm not
sure something something you should
check on I think is [__] writer gild
done Jesus Christ so much mail so much
of that snail mail that paper mail you
know that they send you these gu so
basically what happened was the uh
Writers Guild came to an agreement with
the organization that represents the
studios and the streamers that
organization is called the
amptp um in this there are a bunch of
different things that the Writers Guild
actually got a lot of good [__] there
was a lot done to raise minimums and
solidify writers rooms and all kinds of
stuff y but the AI thing that dudy is
talking about is basically it was a big
point of contention The Writers Guild
was trying to get the studios and the
networks and streamers to agree to never
use AI Instead This is what happened the
networks and streamers said they can use
AI but if they use AI to generate like
an original script or a premise or any
kind of document that uh writer Gil are
you okay
yeah [__] if you use AI if a studio or
network uses AI to generate a first
document then they have to hire a human
to do the first rewrite or the Polish or
whatever and that human
will essentially get IP credit for that
thing no AI can generate a at least per
the agreement no AI generated material
can be the basis for an IP it cannot get
a created by etc etc the human will get
that even if the studio or network hands
you a document generated by their Ai and
you're the first person to write it you
get the credit for that not bad no
that's actually great now there's
another piece of this thing that says
another P go ahead uh human beings can
use AI to generate stuff for the studios
networks and streamers provided that
they disclose they are doing it and the
studio Network or streamer agrees to it
there's nothing in this contract at
least as I read it that has any kind of
rules or regulations around that what if
for example a writer does use something
to gen uh AI to generate an idea and
they don't disclose it and the studio or
network finds out about it what's the
penalty it's unknown that's unknown but
wait a minute there was this sort of
this period where they're going to R
ratify the deal and everyone's going to
sign off on it uh we're in that period
now so that that it's not been ratified
although it really hard to believe that
uh members of the wga wouldn't sign off
on what it'll 100% be ratified right the
wga uh uh negotiation committee has said
this is a great deal they're getting
things that that we didn't know that
we'd be getting of course the the um the
whole uh you know the the the the data
transparency with with streaming and all
the [__] the uh the writers minimums and
stuff it's all good news but what do you
think's going to happen with that
specifically with this AI this loophole
that you found do you think that that's
going to be attested to before the whole
thing's ratified I don't know but I will
say this every writer is going to use AI
if you're not using Ai and you're a
writer you're [__] up you're doing
more work than you have to don't listen
Chachi BT is about to roll out the this
new uh version of itself that's going to
have Dolly 3 embedded and it can do all
kinds of C crazy [__] like you can for
examp the example they're using is you
can take a picture of your refrigerator
open it take a picture and be like what
should I cook for dinner and it'll just
spit out a [__] recipe with the [__]
in your refrigerator things of that
nature are coming so to not be using
tools that are like this powerful to
generate ideas to help but I do the same
thing right um but in terms of writing I
think all writers are going to be using
some form of AI to then have to disclose
that will be redundant it's almost like
telling a studio or network like hey is
it okay if I type the script on a
computer right that's like where we're
we're at now with it so again I don't
know what the penalty is going to be if
there even is one or how they could even
determine if you used AI but you're not
disclosing it the the little claws that
they had in there about like you have to
disclose it and the studio or the
network has to agree that it's okay for
you to use it I just thought was a
little weird yeah you wouldn't want to
lie to the amtp also look you know here
we are uh doing dudy where dudy of
course has all of our info is hacking
into all our [__] and uh well not
hacking again it's an agreement and it's
good it's good that dudy does
that I agree with you yeah that's what
makes the show yeah it's what makes the
show but writers aren't uh going to be
doing that we're not all you know uh
tagged with the whatever neurol link or
some [__] that's going to make uh that's
going to make it transparent to uh
employers that someone isn't using AI
we're we're well I was going to say
[__] but we're not [__] cuz it's
good that dudy does what it what it does
yeah I mean if you're using a let's just
say for example you want to write like a
monologue in a movie or something you
know some characters got their big
moment in the end that's like come on we
got to go out there and win this
basketball game blah blah whatever here
may I just do that now you're the writer
sure and and now come on we get to do we
get to win this b ball b ball his be
ball it's Arnold Schwarzenegger as the
New York Long Island January hey come on
you got to do the B good hey you see
that golden badler hey that's not the
woman that I wouldn't throw a [__] on
there beautiful older women yeah they're
fine like
why uh sure okay so I'm just saying you
can use Chad gbt to at least give you a
first draft of that monologue then you
can go back and tweak it and whatever
and I simply think especially as we are
getting into era where like AI is
basically embedded in all software if
you're going to use Microsoft Word if
you're writing your screenplays in final
draft it will all have an AI tool that
will help you write the [__] then then
you can't get in the way of that people
software developers are doing that corre
it's showing up more and more in even
websites now you know and and let alone
of course as you're saying apps and
stuff yeah impossible to chart I'm I'm
happy obviously that the strikes over I
do think the guild was able to get a lot
of uh good [__] for the membership the
AI thing I think is still in kind of a
murky territory because honestly like it
hasn't shaken out even what this
technology can do yet we're still in
like really the first year and a half
two years of it being available to
Consumers and uh I just as it gets more
powerful I just have no idea how it's
going to affect all this [__] well this
this um agreement is only for three
years correct once it's ratified which I
think was a good thing because the AI
technology that's going to develop in
the next three years is going to be
staggering yeah good thing for both
sides because uh it's really hard to
figure out where AI fits in uh
entertainment and past that daily life
and uh you know all systems of systems
uh you know but it's good here is what
I'm is what is what I'm gathering now 76
episodes in and change I'm really
enjoying I'm really enjoying it and uh I
think Chad I want to say I I know that
this is usually dudy call but I like
what you just said oh I think you did
very well in this um in the segment
thank you and I like your Schwarzenegger
impersonation thank you very much I
added a little something to it a little
color little flavor yeah and uh I think
it was I think it's a pretty good
segment I did pretty good yeah I think
you did you attitude it's a d f day
[__] you too man woo that's gosh [__]
[__] did you see any of that stuff from
the sphere I did and I was it [__]
almost enraged me uh but I will say it
just made me sad cuz I was like all this
beautiful technology and it's going to
waste on a [__] YouTu concert oh take
it back take it back right now be taken
back take it back I'm [__] hey we're
having a good show so far and I just
want you listen they can't hear me right
let me know when they got seal in the
Las Vegas Dome you heard me yeah I
understand Jam I'd go to that show yeah
me too but listen we're going to have a
good show today we are having a good
show yeah but I want us to have a good a
real good show you're going to get what
you
want we're all going to get what we want
today do you hear that kids this part
I'm saying this to everyone at home too
we're gonna have let's have a good show
okay hey everybody it's all a good show
all
right good
show thank you moving on a good show he
golden Bachelor we got the [__]
YouTube we got that new [__] honest s
like a Basketball movie oh a beautiful
time to be alive if you ask me Will and
Chad you are both massive shirt heads
you must now discuss your astonishing
shirt collections with one another don't
leave out any details this is shirt
heads begin what wouldn't consider
myself a shirt head definitely have worn
shirts I'm wearing one now um but this
is kind of like shoee heads you remember
he did this to us oh yeah shoe yeah yeah
yeah yeah it was literally shoee heads
we did a segment where we talked about
some of our shoes um you got some shirts
we've all got shirts I got some shirts I
had a couple of shirts that I like wore
every day when I was 12 13 in that era
there was one that was um there was a
comic book store that I used to go to
all the time with my friends called
Kaboom comics and stuff in a suburb of
Texas is that are they around are they
in other places hell no dude oh wow okay
definitely not but I had their shirt and
I would wear that [__] [__] just free
promotion for them yeah all the time I
absolutely love the shirt yeah those are
cool when you get when you find
something ohy there it is okay dudy God
this picture pulled a quick one there
and uh speaking of pilfering data here's
a picture of Chad in said shirt yeah
that's the shirt and there's your lovely
Mom that's my mom uh wearing a Kansas
City Royals shirt I think that shirt was
also mine but that shirt Kaboom comics
and stuff I think it says 3030 North
josy Lane Carolton Texas check it out I
don't know what's there now was in a
strip mall but uh it had everything
that's where I first played magic that's
where I would buy comic books they had
video games and [__] in there I hung out
there all the time that's cool and
eventually the guy who owned that
[__] store fled the city like we just
showed up one day and it's barred the
door is barred there's a [__] notice
public hearing on the [__] door and
we were like what happened and we never
knew some there was always conjecture
about like he got into some kind of
legal trouble yeah but one day uh all
the [__] was still in the store by the
way we're talking box of magic cards
comic books whatever and so one
day me and a friend of mine I'll call
him my Tomos okay we were uh [__]
around behind the strip mall and we saw
the little ladder that went up on top of
the building we were like we should
[__] climb on top of the building and
see if we can go into Kaboom comics and
take boxes of magic cards so we climb up
there and a [__] cop sees us wo pulls
up behind you know what are you kids
doing up there and uh we had a tennis
ball and and I was telling my buddy as
the [__] cop cars pulling up to us
I'm like we just got to say we
accidentally threw our tennis ball up
here it's fine we came up here to get it
yeah he goes we saw somebody throw a
wallet up here and we were looking for
it I just looked at him like what the
[__] the worst lie imaginable luckily
the cop let us off he did not arrest us
uh nor did we uh find entry we we were
not able to break into the place would
you could you somehow could you recreate
the face that you're making in the
picture with the have a look at this no
cuz I as you can see I had two vampire
fangs coming in and I got braces
specifically because of those vampire
fangs so I can't but I can give you a
kind of like yeah there we go that's
kind of the that's kind of the vibe yeah
real good well that's a good shirt um
yeah I had shirts I also had shirt what
you got what kind of shirts you I dude I
had I had there were well I you know I
wore a lot of shirts yeah dude yeah dude
I wore shirts every day brother yeah
brother hold on dude you got all sorts
of shirts dude and sometimes you take
those shirts and you rip them off
brother that's when you get in the ring
listen uh I had shirts but as I'm sure
you did too yeah I am thinking right now
of one I had jerseys I loved wearing
jerseys Jersey Boy I was a jersey boy I
had football jerseys couple baseball
jerseys but my favorite my favorite
Jersey uh that arguably my favorite
Jersey still got it is my Seattle
Seahawks number 55 Brian Bosworth jersey
you remember this one uh I mean I
remember Brian Bosworth and that he was
drafted by the Seahawks and
played two years SE maybe before he just
flamed out yeah he flamed out and
started making movies and [__] that
fireman movie Stone Cold he made that
movie Stone Cold God yeah what a piece
of [__] that was but uh yeah I had I had
uh I had like that was that was one of
my y hey there he is okay so dudes he
showing us that wowe dude there's a lot
here dud you're you're wearing two
shirts first of all in this there's a
shirt underneath it and you've got a
significant hair do yes I do I had hair
I would have loved to have had male
pattern baldness in uh the ninth grade
when this picture was taken it would
have just really saved me some
embarrassment because I don't think I
look I don't it doesn't make sense for
me to look at myself with hair even with
my uh My Little Chubby uh my little um
uh you know little baby fat face here
but you know the thing about the thing
about this is my ninth grade picture I
look spaced out somewhat I love the
little in the hair like did you go to a
hair stylist no man I just had all sorts
of waves in my hair yeah I had very wavy
hair thank you um this shirt I love this
[__] shirt so much I had a bunch of
jerseys but this was my this was my
favorite as a matter matter of fact I
wore this
shirt in my first my first episode of
Television that I was ever on I was 15
or 16 I did this Canadian show we've
talked about it here on the show it's
called neon Rider where basically the
premise of the show is that it is this
uh there's this guy played by Winston
recer who's sort of this uh um Canadian
Michael Landon type with the speaking of
waves long beautiful hair and um he he
basically there's this Ranch and the
kids get picked up in the city and they
have problems these problem kids and
teenagers with problems and they send
them out to this Ranch you know and then
the guy D straightens them out yeah he
straightens them out and [__] and there
was all these there's all these kids in
it and I played I was uh Eli the
kleptomaniac on the show and you wore
the shirt in that show I wore the shirt
in that show I wore I think I also wore
a Dan Marino Jersey in that show oh my
God you were a jersey boy in the show
too I guess I was a Jersey Boy in the
show but it was
my okay this is odd dudy has this look
at this break Milo no really like after
he pays you and takes you up to his
hotel room or wherever what if he asks
if he can videotape it is that EXT what
if it's a real ugly guy get him Milo you
don't have that kind of money she's a
prute little girl is how can you do it
or someone who makes you want to puke
look as long as she gets paid she'll
take on anything right piggy G leave her
alone
hey don't have to cop Aude man just
having some fun what' you do to get sent
here don't cop drugs at his school oh
what about you oh [__] I I uh I stole
some things he's a klepto and you wow I
tried to burn down my high school great
danger Bay's ocean Helm in there clean
up your own ACT first and then you can
make fun of her okay oh all right [__]
she's coming to the aid of not very
Canadian yeah uh really yeah beautifully
done don't cop AUD just having some fun
yeah um let me ask you this first of all
Jesus Christ how the [__] are you
choosing your own wardrobe in a goddamn
TV show they don't have a wardrobe
Department really good point I think
they got the fat boy there and they were
like hey little fatty do you have some
of your own clothes cuz we don't want to
go shopping they asked you that or was
that just what you were wearing when you
show showed up that day hard to say you
know um I don't know what the budget was
like on the show it's absolutely this
was not cleared by the NFL in any way
but don't cop AUD hey don't cop a having
some
fun um dude I wish you were in that I
wish you were in that show as a matter
of fact let's do it that actor uh not
unlike you was exactly one year younger
than me I remember this kid because he
was like 15 yeah and he I I remember
that he I shouldn't say this but he he
[__] had to go like he did the school
time you know when you're on set and
you're a minor you have to go you know
this there's a union rule they have to
send the kids to a little school time so
they can make up the school workor that
they're missing at school he went and
did that and he's like are you going are
you going to do your school time or did
he he probably said are you going to do
your school time yeah yeah and I said uh
huh cuz I just like skipped I just left
school [__] you I got a TV gig I don't
know and I figured it out when I went
back and then uh so he did the school
and then I look over like after school
and he he was sitting there outside the
trailers having couple smokes with the
at 15 with the crew yeah that's just
what they do just having some smokes
don't cop AUD having some fun smokes fun
you know yeah um just got some singles
at the corner store oh [__] yeah you
could go to that [__] uh petrocan
there there's that [__] one guy Barry
who will sell you he'll open a pack and
sell you singles even though it's Petro
Can 25 cents a you need a Tony tuny get
you two Looney gets you one um I looking
at that Jersey that you were wearing
reminded me I did not ever wear jerseys
but I had a bunch of sports shirts
um most notably I had there was a a time
in the early 9s where these caricature
shirts were very invogue they were like
caricatures of all the biggest athletes
and I had a [__] Bo Jackson one that
I wore the living [__] out of I believe
that shirt deteriorated that I wore it
so much but I loved those old caricature
shirts the Michael Jordan one was a huge
one everybody in my junior I had one
yeah [__] absolutely love those yeah
those are cool the Charles Barkley Keem
I had some Aira shirts I used to wear as
well I I don't know I guess I had a
bunch of t-shirts that I liked as a kid
I had a baseball jersey this is a
Canadian company uh I believe out of
Winnipeg so you probably wouldn't have
access to this there was a thing called
chip and pepper and they were they were
this outfit that whatever it was kind of
like West Beach or Body Glove like they
were trying to Corner that sort of thing
and I had this I had this [__] chip
and pepper uh shirt it was but it was
like a baseball jersey type thing and I
remember one time we were out super late
and uh whatever these [__] anyway we
were like we're probably the same age as
I was doing this damn show and some cops
came like we were definitely trespassing
yeah we were in this [__] Nursery
hanging out like the where the flowers
are and [__] and uh we were over by the
basketball court it doesn't matter the
point is cops came and me and a couple
friends tore across this field cuz they
flashed their lights and we got freaked
out and we ran and then we jumped over
this fence and I got my finger hooked on
the fence and I I slit my my finger open
real good and I there's still a scar is
it this one there it is little Scar and
uh my finger was bleeding profusely so I
had to take off my chip and pepper shirt
no but as you know I'm a two- shirt
[__] yeah right I'm a two- shirt
Jersey Boy so I had a shirt on
underneath which was just skin tight and
looked like I was naked and pale and I
wrapped up my thing and then we ran
across a freeway we ran across Highway
17 to a bus stop where we sat there and
pretended that's where we were and the
cop came down that street street as my
hand was just pulling up with blood and
that's my shirt story for my chip and
pepper shirt yeah well we're shirt heads
sorry about your chip and pepper shirt
dude oh sorry e don't cop a too I'm not
coping a
to just having some fun thank you moving
on you sound like you're uh you sound
like you're in Fargo when you do a
Canadian thing
yeah sometimes I dip into that that's
the beauty of my impersonations they're
uh multi-layer a lot of facets oh yeah
really very complex well I think it's
good that you've been doing impressions
and [__] on the show thanks me too yeah
yeah I'll keep doing them oh great you
know I'm really loving your attitude
this episode I'm being genuine sincerely
I'm also really loving my astonishing
partnership with represent to produce
dudy apparel and accessories you can
find everything at represent.com
store dudy whoa the new Hulu hogo kugan
shirt is going to be the head chef at
the McDonald's executive cafeteria in
thunderbay Ontario Canada oh meanwhile
the good job boner mug was exonerated in
the murder of the ex- head chef at the
McDonald's executive cafeteria in
thunderbay Ontario Canada the CEO of
McDonald's is of course Tom Hayne and
wishes he could be here to tell you more
about it but he's busy shooting the new
Darby
want to see a teaser yes holy [__] Cory
listen to me godamn it I was out in the
deep water again chasing Brown crab and
I found another
[Applause]
Darby this Darby had a prophecy tattooed
on his back every Thousand Years the
number one Darby has to meet up with the
number two uh Darby and transfer its
accumulated knowledge telepathically if
the two darbies don't make take the
transfer the oceans float into space
bye-bye Cincinnati the dby I found is
the number two Darby and he needs our
help to find the number one Darby who
has gone missing I'm just a simple Brown
crab hauler I cannot do this alone come
on core we saved the world the last time
we found a goddamn Derby you want to
save it
again you had me at Brown
crab okay all right okay that's that's
me again and I'm in Darby 2 you were in
Darby one you're also in Darby 2 to
Darby sounds like me a little bit you
had me a brown crab you had me a brown
crab oh man Tom ha first sequel from Tom
Hayne Tom Hae is the hardest working man
in Show Business he's got a new [__]
movie trailer every week he's [__]
making well that's the good thing about
well we'll see how much uh once the the
the deal is ratified how many Tom Hayne
movies we see coming down the pike I for
one can't wait to work with Tom Hayne um
you had me at Brown crab gee whiz that
was [__] insane yeah all right well
anyway when's that sag strike G to end
uh pretty soon I think you know I think
so because it's really just it's the
same [__] it's the you know the
residuals the the transparency with
these [__] streamers so we can get
the damn residuals cuz no one makes
residuals on that you used to be able to
whatever you work a few gigs and that's
about as much as most actors can hope to
do in a year and uh it's nice residuals
are sort of the thing which which makes
sense as you send a product out in the
world you you should uh you should
probably get uh PID for it you know what
I mean anyway hey dude um uh uh uh I
would like to remind everybody now if
you haven't already please subscribe uh
to the show on YouTube of course as I
mentioned we're almost at 100 well we're
not we're just past 60,000 dude we're
almost at 5 million subscribers we've
almost got 5 million there we're getting
closer we would like to cross 100,000 uh
uh uh YouTube followers wouldn't that be
something uh if we could if we could do
that please uh please give the show a
thumbs up and a like And subscribe and
all that stuff and set your
notifications so that way you know when
we're sending out new [__] and and it's
all good and then uh check out uh
Instagram at dudy pod show all sorts of
video [__] happening there all the time
so many ridiculous memes some AI
generated [__] from
dudy most recently a photo of of one of
the things recently was a photo of uh of
your uh reigning defending Undisputed
dudy episode Champion uh generated in Ai
and all of the incredible stuff that
comes through from our pods pal of dudy
um that they make memes and [__]
incredible stuff also that they're doing
over in on Discord one of the
friendliest commun communities you will
ever find if you can head over to
Discord uh check all that [__] out and
uh and uh of course if you are enjoying
the show and would like to show uh your
support and get more dudy please
consider uh subscribing to our patreon
we call it dudy plus and it's a
patreon.com dudy you're going to get uh
brand new episode of dudy after dudy
after every show a bunch of watch alongs
[__] like that there's all sorts of
flavor please share the show all over
the place and follow Chad's light
suggestion of uh of um of uh uh forcing
everybody that you know forced viewing
is the only way to cut through I believe
the noise of the modern media world
there's so much [__] coming at you 24/7
you basically have to be forced to watch
something at this point for stick it's
actually working a lot of we see a lot
of people on the aforementioned uh
Instagram not to mention Tik Tok and
Facebook and and uh comments across uh
the the internet saying that they are
locking people in room rooms and forcing
them to dudy and and uh and it and it
kind of to a nice uh to a nice effect
people kind of come out the other side
going it is a dudul day I'm enjoying
myself with that said uh I would like to
uh uh give you a a moment right now to
to uh do all this [__] subscribe to the
show and do all that stuff and hit the
notifications and that way uh you're all
set to go and we'll finish the show so
and welcome back and I would also like
to say if you have one of these things
called a podcast and you want to have a
guest on that podcast and you would like
that guest to be me episode Champion
Chad culture I accept all requests you
just have to send an email to book Chad
cult gmail.com ask for my attendance I
do these things in 20 minute segments
every Saturday from 10: to 11: a.m. PST
I do three of them every Saturday I just
did three this past weekend had a
[__] blast got to talk a lot of UFOs
a lot of conspiracy theories uh this
weekend and hopefully those will be
coming out soon and then tag me in that
[__] and I'll repost it but um
absolutely love it send that email again
book chat culture gmail.com you get in
the queue I answer them in the order
received he makes he does every [__]
podcast that comes at him on a Saturday
yeah uh I would like to read some
YouTube comments because it's a
wonderful community and and uh it's
something that we do every week this is
from uh at 420 Fernandez on YouTube who
said I've been listening to dudy on
Spotify for a minute now I've never seen
the intro and now that I have I will
never be the same dudy has taken a piece
of my soul and I am here for it that's
that's really cool to hear a lot of
people are of course listening to the
show oh that's how podcasts work dude
and but then they check it out on
YouTube and of course there's all sorts
of visuals well that's a different
experience brother cuz when you listen
you're hearing but when you look you see
dude
you could do that any old time though
thank you yeah on your own time and you
love it right oh yeah oh it's yes yes I
do yes and it's good that you do that
thank you I enjoy what you're doing yeah
dude you love okay so anyway here's the
next one oh wow macho man taking a [__]
you you can do here's what you can do
for me why don't you do Hulk Hogan in
the bathtub and then when your your
bum's all clean and you're ready make a
poopy cuz you were in the warm uh bath
and all of your guts did their garbles
and marbles go take a [__] and do your
Macho Man and leave it there this one is
from Vincent half price 9930 we see what
you did there yeah writer strike ends
and we get a brand new segment of pizza
the movie all in one week this is truly
the greatest timeline uh last week's
show was the eighth installment of pizza
the movie so thank you Vincent half
price that's nice this one is from
Bas Ventura 8813 says seeing Will's
battle to have a good time but being a
tiny bit scared of dudy is so [__]
funny I love it I'm watching this
episode for the third time great episode
guys yeah real nice of you uh repeat
viewing yeah but I'm not I was I'm not
scared I'm not scared of dud yeah you
can't be scared of dudy this [__] guy
yeah just
I know we all like see what you're doing
it's what I'm doing you're f d you
[__] said you love my impersonations
I'm giving you what you I'm being
[__] sarcastic and dudy goes halfway
through the show and it's like hey I
really like your attitude sincerely and
then this guy is is over here I don't
even give a [__] it's all good just I
don't I got nothing to say this week
about that uh this one is from at cow
perm handsome Chad is the heel the
podcast world needs well said cow perm
because he's definitely healing it up
our top guy is a heal uhuh but not for
long Yeah because sometimes you try to
do an impersonation or impression but
it's it's not pure yeah we got to have
the unadulterated yeah there he go he's
making a sometimes sometimes the baby
face turns heel dude you should know
something about that brother uhuh yeah
and maybe you should save your wo sound
for the farts you make in your bathtub
because that's what it sounds like when
he tries to go wool he
goes and then he goes yeah yeah all
right anyway uh thanks cow perm good
stuff really good stuff I'm still
feeling
great and will I put this next
astonishing segment in today's show
specifically for you it's an opportunity
to shine what you do with that
opportunity or don't do with it is
completely up to you and I'm going to
tell you up front I didn't make it easy
come on Will Shine for me you can do
this this is Jessie Venture AT ad reads
begin okay what does that mean didn't
make it easy I don't know we're going to
find out I guess all right uh Jesse
Ventura ad reads one of my favorite segs
it's a great segment ah it's a great
segment we're three for three so far D
really good stuff and I'm really
enjoying it and
uh uh Jessie vour ad
reads first one is you're going to know
exactly all
right it's time to party at
Arby's we're back at Arby's because for
a limited time Arby's is partnering with
the
oh okay all right because for a limited
time Arby's is partnering with the
feature film Derby 2 to
Darby dude to bring you the Arby's Darby
22 Darby double BOGO beef and potato
extra value meal deal for the rest of
this month if you simply say I'm in the
Darby Arby's AR me when you purchase any
Arby's beef sandwich with a side of
potato product you'll qualify for a
second Arby's Darby 2 two Darby's double
BOGO beef and potato extra value meal so
put on your party hat and join the
Arby's Derby
Army let me tell you about joining the
Army at a new recruit intake in
1972 just out outside of Tacoma
Washington an 8 foot6 man covered in
body hair drenched in the aroma of the
lomy forest floor and unable to speak
except for basic Grunts and gestures
broke every basic training record in the
history of the Armed Forces so why don't
you tell me if the greatest soldier in
American history was a
Bigfoot with a CIA kidnap and attempted
to read in a secret P project that
spanned decades called operation Forest
sire all right so Arby's we got a new
BOGO Double B BOGO ass beef and potato
extra value meal deal yeah it's a Darby
to two darbies meal deal from Arby right
sometimes fast food places do that
they'll team up with a movie some kind
of like cross promotion or whatever I
guess that's what Darby to team with
[__] Orbeez yep all right that was a
good one all right um here's the next
one if you thought the Arby's Darby 2
two Darby double BOGO beef and potato
extra value meal deal was the best BOGO
deal around think again [__]
Togos is is it is it Togos or Tojo I
think it's Togo Togos Togos is getting
into the BOGO game with a new
mascot
Bo Bobo the Togo's mustard
clown and for a limited time when you
purchase a Togo's Bobo Mojo potato
platter your drink comes with a special
peel off Togo's Bobo Mojo potato logo
which can be redeemed for a Togos Bobo
Mojo potato logo BOGO potato
basket Jesus and don't forget to enjoy
one of Togo's famous flaming mango
Mojitos well let me tell you something
about flaming
Mojitos they were they were the forest
sire favorite
drinks the only thing that could calm
his nerves after a long day of being
experimented on and an anthropologist
working on the project named Terry
Harvey made the forest sire's favorite
Mojitos over the years the two became
bonded and even though no words were
spoken Dr Garvey began to become
sympathetic to the forest sire pleas to
be freed from the confined torture of
the CIA and on the forest sire's 40th
birthday both he and Dr Garvey
disappeared from the project and they
were never seen or heard from again so
why don't you tell me if Garvey and the
forest sire developed a romantic
relationship can't Jesus sh [__] kill
me dude so the big foot seeing spots the
forest sire the forest sire so the
forest sire is a Bigfoot that the CIA
kidnapped from the Army put it into a
breeding program and now the there was a
doctor that I guess had a romantic
relationship with fores who is broken
for a sire out of CIA custody yeah makes
sense yeah because because Togos yeah
dude that makes sense here's the last
one uh the the Togos BOGO universe is
expanding in addition to Bobo the Togos
mustard clown Togos is proud to announce
a new BOGO partnership with Yoko
Ono no for limited time you can meet
yokoo and Bobo the mustard clown when
they host a Togos yokoo and Bobo BOGO
Bingo night at your local
Togos Togos yokoo and Bobo BOGO Bingo
has prizes food and fun and for a
limited time you can get yokoo Idaho
Loco
potatoes with the purchase of any yokoo
album Togo's Yoko Ono and Bobo Bingo is
fun for the whole family well let me
tell you about a whole family the forest
sire was in CIA captivity for nearly two
decades before his disappearance with Dr
Garvey and in that time they were never
able to successfully breed him with any
other creature but about 15 years after
his disappearance a kid showed up at a
Tacoma High School try out for a
basketball team he was 8 fo8 Haier than
he should have been and smelled of crush
leaves and crisp fall
air he broke every Washington State High
School basketball record in existence
then he disappeared so why don't you
tell me if the forest sire proved that
he was able to breed just not in
captivity by having a child with Dr
Garvey
who drew too much attention for his
basketball skills and was eventually
kidnapped by the CIA and put in the same
breeding program as his father was in 15
years
[Music]
prior I can't do [__] hell
H
yokoo potato yeah put that belt down
take that
off thank you moving on leave the belt
on the floor for me cuz later today I'm
going to pick up the the belt there well
that was great too hey man real good
show real where it needs to be that was
absolutely [__] incredible my eyes
are watering I'm sweating from that uh
wowe yep [__] Yoko own oh gee whiz
why the why why is Jesse Ventura
referring to this um the Bigfoot is of
forest sire the forest
sire I don't know an interesting name I
like Forest sire yeah me too yeah maybe
there's a pretty good performance will I
have to admit I think that was one of
your best venturers let's see if you can
keep it up we've done this three times
before and all three times Chad has
succeeded and will you have failed to
bring in an astonishing vegan dessert so
I thought I'd give you one more chance
you have no idea how badly I want to see
you do the right thing here my fingers
are crossed come on will you've never
had to fight for anything in your life
fight for this this is vegan aers volume
4 Will's last chance begin Will's last
chance all right dude did you do it well
Chad or do you want me to go first you
want to make this suspenseful you know
why don't you go first and then we'll
see what happened this week on veganator
the fourth and did I hear dudes say
final chance well it's your Last Chance
yeah dudy was saying to do this all
right I'll go first I will oblige
however you want to roll this out
whatever kind of dramatic Insurance you
want to make for whatever you brought or
didn't bring look what he's got there uh
this is a uh a little bowl of vegan
snicker
doodles yep finger them all so that I
can't eat any of them thank you you made
snicker doodles dude vegan snicker
doodles oh the Sugar's the Sugar's
flaking off on my hands yeah oh I can't
wait what can you tell us about the
preparation of these snicker doodles
before there's some coconut uh mixture
in them there is some other vegan
ingredients some secret vegan
ingredients you got your cinnamon you
got your sugar you can dip them in Chads
cup of coffee in the big time actually I
kind of ruined the flavor there but
let's see yeah
dude what do you think these are
fantastic and I wouldn't have guessed
they're vegan I know dude these are good
I know oh LLY I know you want oh he's
smelling them oh no I you could eat
these L these a for you he woke up
that's the [__] thing he wakes up for
yeah a little bit of sugar is okay bu
dude these are fantastic vegan Snicker
doodle uh among my favorite vegan
desserts Laura and I made
these your wonderful girlfriend Laura
and you made these uh snicker doodles
yeah vegan snicker
doodles dude these are fantastic and I
should say you know it it it needs to be
said and and thank you for what needed
to be said yeah um take it easy man this
is
um it's always inspiring to see that you
make these and then you bring them into
the show and the last time we did this I
did feel bad that I didn't make you
something we read a YouTube comment the
week after we did it where someone's
like you never make something for chat
and I apologize cuz it's like you know
what you're busy making these um you're
busy making these uh vegan treats and
they're delicious and even lulio thinks
so you can't eat this no dude it's not
for you was look at him wait lick his
mouth LLY oh L can't have
oh so close so close but um but uh in
even despite what dudy says hey Will
it's your last chance ra ra ra I I still
you know know I the onus is on me not
only to provide you out there with uh
with entertainment here on the dudy Pod
show which is what it's all about but I
also believe it's uh incumbent on me to
be a good friend and that's why Chad
MH this week on the show
yeah
I sorry enjoyed a good
here let me eat the rest of this cookie
first
oh oh yeah they're very good that recipe
is a
winner that's why this week CH yeah
that's why this
week hold on okay well well first you
got to eat and then you drink that's why
this week I have prepared oh [__] a
vegan dessert for my pal Chow I had a
little help
from lulio with this and a lot of help
from my uh my wonderful wife Molly okay
who um among many incredible things that
she's done in the culinary world as a
private Chef she was also she also
worked in a bakery in her youth oh
essentially running a bakery at like the
age of [__] 18 or something that's
cool uh in up in Chico California Chad
this is here's a napkin okay and here's
a dessert fork okay and here is the most
delicious berry crumble that you could
find in the vegan dessert sphere this is
all for me that's all for you are you
eating any of it uh well uh last night I
might have had a little Gabus and uh put
away a good amount of it by myself you
ate three4 of this thing already M was
like why don't you save some you know so
you can enjoy it on the show and I like
what kind of berries I see some
blackberries in here probably some Raz
in here um it's actually just strawberry
and giant ass blackberries those are my
favorite I eat them every morning in my
oatmeal right boy let's take a let's
take a bite
here that's [__] great dude I did it
I did it give me the belt four out of
four [__] we talked about the strike
and I knew a thing or two there then we
talked about shirts dude and then after
that we did some oh look at him go yeah
really good it's good yeah you like it
it is great oh man
oh boy yeah well what we did was I
mostly watched my wonderful wife make it
but
um you know what you do you take some
ingredients and you put them together
and then you [__] out a vegan dessert
what's the crust made out of the
crumble uh it's it's um oats it's just
it's oats and then there's some corn
starch and some flour and
cornstarch oh jeez um and uh you know
some uh some brown sugar it's it's kind
of light on the sugar we try to rely
mostly on the berries I don't know how
you feel about Stevia I'm always
throwing Stevia and everything I'm not a
big fan of it but no yeah you don't is
it in here uh no oh I was like I can't
even taste it in here no yeah stev great
this is really really
tasty hey hold on a second yeah I always
have a dessert Fork Fork right next to
me let me just forgot what this tastes
like in order to really execute the
segment I need to you got it you good oh
yeah I'm good mhm yeah it's just as good
as I remember it last night have another
bite here I'll have a bite with some
strawberry yeah lulio you want to just
lick my Fork here here hold on oh I give
him a little strawberry oh L he finally
got his treat yeah dude this was really
fantastic thank you for making it I
appreciate it and I'm enjoying it I
don't want you to feel like I did it
just for the show Chad I want you to
understand that you're my pow chow and
you're deserving of homemade uh vegan
desserts same same to you dude I feel
the same way and I and everyone in our
audience is deserving of
homemade uh vegan desserts not just [__]
that I buy at Whole Foods I think people
should uh take veganator out into their
lives and demand that their friends make
them vegan desserts you know what would
be a good thing to do here's a call to
action for the show if you force uh your
friend to consume the dudy Pod show and
they enjoy it then uh let them know that
they can simply pay you back by uh
making a vegan dessert yeah have a
veganator night have all your friends
come over bring vegan desserts have all
the [__] gabis you can stand gabis
the Gabus you can stand and then just
[__] [__] house a bunch of vegan
desserts that's a fun night that would
actually be a pretty good uh dude's
evening those were really um bring your
vegan dessert to your dude's evening
party yep those who' have been riding
with us uh since the beginning know that
December 28th is dude's evening um and I
have uh I have a I have a uh a spoiler
not a prediction I have a feeling that
on this dude's evening I'll be see you
later LLY I'll be uh I'll be I'll be
showing up in all sorts of festive gear
oh not the least of which will be that
[__] belt I I say no chance but you
know maybe you I do think you turned
into a pretty good episode today I guess
we'll see thank you by the way already
know you got cut off thank you moving on
I wonder what that means I know what
you're getting for dude's evening oh
what am I getting for dude's evening
gota wait till dude's evening dude ah
[__] last year I got you a an album even
though you don't have a record player
I'm about to get one though I think oh
really I have two records I want to use
now that one and another one what was
what was the one I got you I forgot it
was like a uh oh it was like a '90s hit
80s '90s hits kind of thing yeah and you
got me that bottle I still use that
water bottle it's in my truck oh nice
dude yeah I use it all the time that way
I can guzzle water on the road it's it's
uh it's 1.5 gallon just like my um just
like this [__] thing hey speaking of
this [__] thing if you want to go
over to Pal audi.com you can get all of
the the uh the stickers and [__] um that
we put on here uh Co Cody howburn and
his wonderful wife Jessica and there's a
new one look it's dudy season 1 that's
cool dude yeah it's a pretty cool new
sticker I haven't figured out where I'm
going to put it maybe I'll take off this
this um this sticker with you and put it
right over top of that nice that one of
you good placement dude yeah I'll take
that one off and put it on there you can
take off the sticker but you're not
getting the
belt was that Jessie Ventura taking a
[__] it's all wresters taking a [__]
this concludes the historic 76th episode
of dudy Will and Chad you scored a 99
bringing your cumulative total to
7,189 you only have
2,811 more points to acrew before you
reach your first goal of 10,000 does
matter last week you guys talked about
the series of shorts Chad made for his
40th birthday called copters and you've
both mentioned a pilot you wrote and
produced for CBS called waiting to die
multiple times this week I want you to
watch all of copters and waiting to die
starring TJ Miller Josh Gad Josh Lawson
Sarah Wright Jillian Bell and Edie
Patterson and I'll make that watch along
available on dudy plus this Friday
thanks to everyone for joining us this
week until next week call me dudy holy
dude that's going to be [__] fun
we're going to watch waiting to I have
not seen it't watch that in a while in a
minute yeah it's been a while since okay
so you going to want to check that out
Friday uh 12:00 noon Pacific is when the
the these things come out we're going to
watch waiting to dieet and we're going
to watch all 30 episodes of copters
they're only a minute long listen uh I
want to say this about waiting to die
and copters stacked cast in both
projects sure I don't know about I don't
know about copters that cast but scad
Jillian Bell uh [__] TJ Miller Edie
Patterson Josh Lawson the great Josh
Lawson damn [__] [__] that's GNA be fun
oh boy you're GNA want to check that out
dudy uh
patreon.com dudy and we're going to
watch the copters and thing okay well
[__] and you're definitely going to want
to check out dudy after dudy at the end
of it I'm going to be taking that belt
home and that's all I have to say about
that it's a DY for
[Music]
day and it is a dudy full day today in
particular cuz uh at the end of dudy
after dudy dudy names the episode
champion and today that's going to be me
cuz I had a Flawless show and we scored
99 which is a lot of points so enjoy
that while it lasts you know it's Dy
jumping it's jumping yeah yeah it's
alive yeah look at that it's
alive um you know uh it's dudy after
dudy it's it's a just it's a chill hang
uh and we really enjoy doing it
because even though I enjoy everything
that dudy does especially today uh dudy
after dudy is our chance to just [__]
around you know what I mean we'll talk
about the show that was we'll discuss
whatever the [__] we want we might smoke
a little gabis uh might and it's going
to be it's going to be uh it's going to
be a good one cuz we got we got 99
points I know dude that's aot of points
High marks for sure I wonder if
50 of those points are coming my way I
just need come on guys I just need 50
points give me a break I don't know
about all that well I guess we'll see I
guess we'll see what happens it's dudy
after dudes welcome to dudy after dudy
the flagship weekly show of dudy plus if
you'd like to join us visit patreon.com
dudy okay boys I have some real thinking
to do today I'm going to go figure out
who should be today's episode Champion
have fun without me this is dudy after
dudy begin hey man uh we got to talk
about this right away because we talked
about it a little bit uh during the show
the sphere the sphere in Las Vegas the
state-of-the-art $2.5 billion I think uh
uh structure 2.5 billion that's a good
impression very good and and continue
um uh the sphere with this incredible
screen the largest you know screen in
the [__] world ra You2 is playing
there for the next two or three months
or whatever and uh it's got me thinking
um because I've been watching some clips
of that it's just it's it's it's an
incredible it's it's it's an incredible
venue and what if Chad what if someday I
don't know you know they probably have
to maybe start you know maybe a few
contracts fall through and uh maybe they
get they get an opening or something
what if someday there's a dudy
alive in the sphere yeah that would wow
dude I mean that would I would [__]
absolutely love that I think it would be
more than contracts falling through
though I think it would have to be a
full collapse of society and we get to
go there and become the desert kings the
desert kings is that's the U that's
going to be the the sequel to The what
was that other thing that we did the
Kings two kings [__] around yeah
anyway whatever
hey here's here's what I was thinking
though you remember when we did dudy
alive at the Brea Improv in Brea
California and we packed the place with
all of of you incredible pods P of dudy
and uh dudy started playing a bunch of
AI images behind us during the show
wouldn't it be funny and I know that
dudy is probably going to cut this part
out and we'll get into the dudy uh you
know dudy after dudy patreon.com dudy to
check it out uh so I'm saying this just
to say it even though probably won't be
on the the free YouTube uh and podcast
version of the show you know it' be
funny to see uh as a visual as huge as
the sphere in Las
Vegas Adam Sandler biting Dwayne Johnson
on his
[__] please tell a friend then r
r if you like d what
you please tell a friend
then if you like
d please tell a friend then